(langue autochtone)
- Les élèves participent,
ce matin, à une cérémonie
de purification. Ils n'ont que
trois et quatre ans, mais déjà,
ils apprennent à vivre ce rituel
sacré en langue wolastoqey.
La plus jeune élève de
la classe est Mimigis. Sa mère
veut que son immersion commence
dès maintenant. Les parents et
les bébés sont les bienvenus.
"J'apprends moi aussi, alors
on va apprendre ensemble
(chant autochtone)
Des aînés vienne
régulièrement en classe
transmettre la langue et la
culture aux petits. La présence
de Maggie Paul est précieuse.
(chant autochtone)
Elle est l'une des rares
qui parlent encore couramment
le wolastoqey. Maggie est
émerveillée par l'apprentissage
rapide des enfants.
"Des fois, on voudrait
pleurer de joie parce qu'ils
comprennent, ils comprennent."
(langue autochtone)
L'enseignante, Kelsey Nash-
Solomon, fait tout cququ'elle
peut avec les enfants
pour que les mots viennent
facilement et elle est
patiente et déterminée.
"On n'a pas appris la langue
à la maison.Ça me rend très
émotive parce que c'est qui nous
sommes et d'où nous venons."
(langue autochtone)
Kelsye parles aujourd'hui
le Wolastoqey parce qu'à l'âge
adulte, elle a suivi un cours
universitaire intensif.
(langue autochtone)
"Cette école m'a apportée
beaucoup de joie et
la guérison", explique
la directrice. Guérison
parce qu'on a refusé de lui
enseigner le wolastoqey enfant.
La langue n'était pas valorisée,
l'anglais l'était.
Lisa Perlie Dutcher a
elle aussi suivie un cours
universitaire pour apprendre
sa langue.
(chant autochtone)
Puis, elle a décidé d'ouvrir
cette école d'immersionpour sau.
Avec son équipe elle trouve
du financement, conçoit
des livres, prépare la matière
pour les prochaines années.
L'objectif est d'avoir
10 élèves par niveau jusqu'à
la cinquième année.
L'école Kehkimin est située
dans des locaux loués à la ville
de Fredericton. Éventuellement,
elle va déménager dans
cette maison qu'il faut
d'abord rénover.
Jeremy Deutcher est
un allié de taille de Lisa.
C'est sofifils. Il a remporté
un prix Juno et et Polaris
pour son premier album
qui fusionne de la musique
classique et de vieux chants
enen wolastoqey.
(langue autochtone)
♪ ♪ ♪
Pendant ses spectacles,
il invite sa mère sur scène.
Il fait la promotion de l'école
et il mène une campagne
de fanancement.
"Ça me touche profondément
qu'il ait une si grande
passion pour sa culture
et notre langue."
"Prêter ma voix et
ma notoriété, c'est le moins
que je puisse faire pour
cette cause merveilleuse."
♪ ♪ ♪
(tambours)
Tout naturellement, Jeremy
sort une tambour et chante
avec Maggie et sa mère Lisa.
Tous les trois croient
au succès de lcocole, mais
il y a des sceptiques.
Certains craignent que
les élèves ne soient
désavantagés à l'extérieur du
programme scolaire provincial.
Lisa n'en croit rien.
(langue autochtone)
C'est au tour de Muwin
de réciter la prière dans
le tipi installé dans la cour
de l'école, sous le regard
bienveillant du grand chef
traditionnel Ron Tremblay.
Il croit, lui aussi, en l'avenir
de cette école.
Tous reconnaissent que
la tâche est immense, mais
le rêve l'est tout autant.
Ici Michèle Brideau,
Radio-Canada, Fredericton